moi je suis dans ta bande annonce
logique de favre film c'est là que j'ai
deux phrases deux personnages dans le
film est là une phrase de moi dans le
monde à nous quatre ouais mais c'est pas
personnage d'isaac pourquoi tu m'as mis
dans la banda mais pourquoi mais parce
que séville est tué dans le film mais
pourquoi sultan hachim walid est de 2,2
de faire une bombe je peux toucher aux
fils thierry et karine d'une trisomie
non je ne serai jamais non c'est vrai je
les dis allez faire quoi
j'ai fait du doublage de la pub de la
synchro mais je ne suis pas un acteur de
bande annonce oui mais pourquoi je suis
dans ton film 1 qu'est ce que c'était
fait mal pour que tu me met dans son
film tout
n'est pas tellement non pas du tout il
faut fouiller des trucs qui sont fort de
folie c'est chouette c'est celle ci du
choc feeling à force de ton jeu c'est
qu'on ne sait jamais où elle personnages
ont aidé à traiter en toi c'est ça qui
est passionnant c'est surtout maintenant
dejean la bande annonce c'est plus ça
oui tu pense qu'il faut faire une bande
annonce pour annoncer cette bande
annonce
ça c'est une idée
mais il faut qu'elle soit très très
courte
[Musique]